um all right so if you like your person
Love Is in the Air just ahead of
Valentine's Day it's a day centered
around making your loved ones feel
special Victoria Saha gives us a look at
a newly released book written by a local
couple that explains how to maintain a
healthy relationship
how you leave them feeling written by
Lisa and Jesse Farrell a Las Vegas
couple who came up with the idea for the
book during the covid-19 pandemic when
socializing was limited but we were
stuck at home with our family there are
people that don't even know how to be
together the anxiety the depression the
feelings of being just of angst in this
book the Pharaohs offer tips and advice
to couples that they felt were a game
changer in their relationship when it
came to communication because when
communicating with a partner sometimes
how you leave them feeling is just as
important as how you feel if there's too
much emotion built around something that
you're really upset about maybe take a
bit of a stand down so you can remove
the emotion from what you're feeling
before you share it and taking time for
yourself is very important there are
three absolutes that I live by and
there's three absolutes that Jesse lives
by you know knowing these things would
really be helpful
to put in a book fair all says those
absolutes could be anything from giving
your partner their space to do a certain
morning routine to watching their
favorite show for some alone time
whatever it may be Farrell says there is
always room for improvement for any
relationship Victoria Saha 8 News Now
how you leave them feeling is now
available to purchase on Amazon apple
and Audible